hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to some of the first impressions
of one of the first flagship smartphones
of 2017. that's the lg g6 uh successor
to the g5 pretty much just in the name
because everything else is completely
different there is a bunch of new stuff
with this phone i mean you can see that
just by looking at it but this is going
to be my top five so top five best new
features of the g6 and i'm going to put
them in order so enough of this order
doesn't matter stuff i'm going to tell
you exactly where i think things rank as
the best new features of this phone
let's get started so number five is the
software the g6 is still rocking an lg
software skin but it is a much improved
way less in your face version of it so
it's still very lg with no app drawer
and the skinned apps and icons and
things and a very colorful look but it's
not too crazy and i'd say it's an
improvement over what we had on the g5
and g4 and previous phones it's built on
top of android 7.1 nougat which means
first of all you do get google assistant
baked in now as you do with any nougat
phone and it means you get a couple
other features that are built into lg's
skin that you wouldn't get in pure stock
android that you'd have on the pixel
phone there's always a balance of
shoving new features in your face which
is kind of like what samsung might do
versus sort of tucking the features away
in a settings app and letting you find
them later and i think this skin does a
pretty good job of balancing those two
things but of course it's not perfect as
a skin phone you kind of have inherently
a little bit of a delay as far as
software updates go of course we hope it
gets lots of software updates very
quickly but there's no guarantees and
also of course you kind of have to deal
with lg's reputation lately it's been a
little bit shaky as far as stability
goes but we'll see so number four is the
specs this is the part where i spit a
bunch of numbers and letters at you that
are both higher and better than the
numbers and letters from last year so
2.3 gigahertz snapdragon 821 chip with
the adreno 530 gpu 4 gigabytes of ram 32
gigs of storage is great you have the
twin 13 megapixel cameras on the back
and a 3
300 milliamp hour battery and it's ip68
water resistant that on top of qi
enabled wireless charging and it still
has a micro sd card slot so up to two
terabytes of expandable storage so the
numbers and the specs on paper of course
look great as you'd expect from a
flagship android phone in 2017 we don't
have a price yet so it's kind of hard to
place this in the bang for the buck
category but obviously it looks really
good and there's no real flaws here but
of course again it's not quite perfect
uh in the us version you're actually not
getting a quad dac you're getting a
pretty average dac instead you're
getting a couple extra radios which
again it's a different consumer in a
different region but you're also not
getting a snapdragon 835 chip obviously
in this phone that's another bleeding
edge high-end chip that you'll probably
see in phones as soon as a month from
now like the galaxy s8 in march now
that's not to say that the snapdragon
821 is way worse or that it can't hang
it's just that's what you get for
putting out a phone a little bit early
in the year is you don't get the brand
new silicon that sort of comes out after
you put your phone out so later phones
will have the snapdragon 835 821 is
still really good but you know not
perfect so number three is the dual
cameras on the back last year the g5 had
a very obviously primary 16 megapixel
portrait camera and a very obviously
secondary low resolution super wide
angle camera just for fun this year the
g6 gets twin 13 megapixel sensors behind
your standard and 120 degree wide angle
lenses so now when you're switching back
and forth between the portrait lens and
the super wide angle lens it's not as
big of a glaring difference in quality
before you could really tell when a
photo was with the other camera now
you'll just sort of be able to glide
between the two and not get a huge drop
off and i think that's the kind of thing
that will encourage people to use this
super wide angle camera a lot more it
was pretty cool feature to see in the g5
they're carrying it over to the g6 and
i'm happy it's there but it's not it's
it's not perfect because obviously okay
no camera is perfect but also because
i've had some stability issues in this
first bit of use but i can't look too
far into that because this is a
pre-production unit with pre-production
software so i can pretty much guarantee
that this and any other problem i come
across in the software will be fixed by
the time this goes on sale so the number
two best feature in the g6 is the design
the design of the g6 is completely new
it's ditched the modular nature of the
g5 for a much more you could say
traditional premium smartphone design so
just metal and glass everywhere still
has the volume buttons on the side which
i really like and it keeps the
trademarked and loved lg power button
and fingerprint reader on the back
which also happens to complete this face
that you can see in making i mean you do
see it right and honestly the robot face
kind of matches because this phone has a
very robotic squared up look like
there's no unnecessary tapers to try to
make it feel thinner or look thinner
there's no fancy edge display bleeding
over the edge with curved glass none of
that crazy fancy stuff it's just very
business-like and all the way around and
i kind of like that or maybe it's
because i've been using the pixel too
much i don't know it's gorilla glass on
the front and back and this thing is
obviously waterproof like we mentioned
earlier so ip68 means it can survive if
you get caught in the rain or you drop
your phone in a puddle or a shower or
something
it does all this while keeping usb type
c it keeps the headphone jack it keeps
the expandable storage with a micro sd
card slot so with all that i don't mind
it being a little bit thicker in the
hand because the footprint is definitely
manageable but as you could probably
guess it's not perfect uh you could say
that you would have liked to have had a
removable battery like we had with the
g5 you don't get that it's not a huge
deal but that's something to note and
also the single downward facing speaker
is not the best part of this phone at
all and that's something that i've noted
with a lot of previous flagships but
obviously the ones that focus on the
speaker get to do it a lot better than
this so not perfect so that brings us to
number one the best feature of the g6
which is right up here at the front and
that's the display the screen is
obviously the main attraction here it's
a 5.7 inch ips lcd display with an 18 by
9 aspect ratio which is
you know two by one i know my fractions
so the display is a little taller or a
little wider sideways than your normal
16x9 display it's a 2880 by 1440
resolution now apps and wallpapers and
icons and everything still work
perfectly normally but you do get a
couple software features to take
advantage of the larger display at
multitasking for example works a bit
better now that you have that extra bit
of room i mean it's essentially two
square windows now top to bottom or side
by side and more apps are compatible
with it thanks to android nougat and on
top of just being a little bit longer
it's obviously still a great display as
you can tell it gets super bright up to
600 nits so very viewable outdoors
supports hdr and is very proud of it
giving very deep blacks for an lcd and
great saturation and the curved corners
are just icing on the crispy g6 cake i
mean i could go either way on curved
corners versus square but i think they
look kind of cool so i don't mind it and
this thinness of the bezels is really
what lg's been hyping up and what people
looking at this phone will hype up
because it's not just the side bezels
which are obviously tiny but it's the
forehead and the chin the top and bottom
bezels they get super compact too so
these thin bezels all the way around the
display let a phone with a 5.7 inch
screen
fit in the footprint of a much smaller
phone which is legitimately useful again
but then again you can say with me again
it's not perfect anytime you're watching
a 16x9 video it becomes obvious you're
gonna see these bars along the side and
people get used to seeing these bars
along watching most videos but if you
watch an 18 by nine or two by one video
the bars go away and it looks way better
and also obviously smaller bezels make
this phone a lot less protected and more
prone to cracking or breaking if you
were to drop it especially if you don't
have a case on it which like me is how i
roll with every phone so that's just
something i'm willing to deal with so
that's the g6 in a first impressions
nutshell things like performance and
battery life and the camera these will
all be thoroughly tested and that's the
kind of stuff i'll go over with you in
the full review of this phone when this
thing finally comes out with a price and
a release date but until then that's uh
that's what to know about it you can
look at the g6 as pretty much a super
safe bet but in a good way like it seems
to stack up well against what we're
expecting from things like the galaxy s8
and phones coming out later this year
but again those will have to come out
we'll look at that comparison when we
get to it so either way what do you
think of this phone would you grab a g6
let me know thanks for watching talk to
you guys in the next one
peace